because I justice it's his first as a
steel steel feel and wall starting
together for the six consecutive seasons
shot was there deflected by corner
picked up by Russian team they've never
went to within four I'm on the outside
looking in you don't get your act
together let's peel tale by two
intercepted by Jorge number one in
steals the other way you'll put this
over rebound fought for my he me grabs
it inside offensive for back to wall
down goes Westbrook inside it's lost
toppled in by Adams and back up on his
horses Westbrook the trouble
he is magnificent we've seen the 160
plus games yes he was one of those
stretched for 20-plus points or more
punch the bestie guard play
as he stashes in for the dues and he's
got 31 and 6 in the fourth
POS gone pickpocket by George
[Applause]
and everything he's throwing up is going
down he's got an 18-point fourth-quarter
Russell Westbrook
he's got 39 who has 11 since they got 14
in here in the second half and 11 here
in the second half for a total of 14
Westbrook still a beautiful depth dive
down the lane Oh Bray will try to find
the open man knocked away by Adams and
[Applause]
as all she wrote